come back to peers of organized census
what model Emily radachowski one of my
favorite dimwits about controversy
recently by claiming that getting
divorced before 30 is chic
so it seems that a lot of ladies are
getting divorced
before they turn 30 and as someone who
got married at 26 has been separated for
a little over a year
32. I don't think there's anything
better if there is nothing better than
being in your 30s still being hot maybe
having a little bit of your own money
figuring out what you want to do with
your life for all of those people who
are stressed or feeling stressed about
that about being divorced like it's a
it's it's good congratulations
it's like congratulations
she's ridiculous well divorce is
certainly becoming more common and
marriage itself is becoming a fierce
Frontier in the Raging culture wars on
one side there are feminist rejecting a
deity concept on the other so-called
Trad wives you think it binds our
societies together we're trying to spend
their days due to the cooking and
cleaning while their husbands go to work
Esther Williams is a 25 year old Trad
wife has amassed hundreds of thousands
of followers by showing off her traged
wife life online if you can give up a
job to be the perfect wife so is she and
others like a saving Society or are they
selling out The Sisterhood well join me
now is traditional wife and influencer
Esther Williams and in the studio I'm a
socialist and author Grace Blakely and
YouTuber Pearl Davies this might be the
best lineup in the history of Television
for a a debate of this nature so I'm
very exciting all right Ashley Williams
let's start with you is the the Trad
wife sell it to me why do you think we
should all go back to having Trad wives
in marriages
um well I believe that well I actually
don't believe that everyone should be a
traditional wife I think that it is a
choice and I think it's a lovely choice
if a woman wants to Simply Be a wife and
a mother and that's enough for her and
it's it's a simple way of living with
traditional gender roles
um it's balanced and we don't have to do
it all as women I think we've proven
that um
it's possible but at what cost right
right and and in terms of what being a
Trad wife involves what do you think it
means to be a tread wife
well to adhere to traditional gender
roles so what I mean by that is the
husband he is the provider of the home
he goes out he works and he he knows how
to protect his family if need be and the
wife she's the Homemaker she does the
cooking she does the cleaning and she
takes care of the home and children if
there are any and
um herself of course so that's it's
adhering to traditional gender roles
okay grace I'm sure you thoroughly agree
with this
said about the fact that women should be
able to choose obviously I completely
agree and you know men should be able to
choose as well I think the feminist
critique of traditional gender roles and
gender ideology isn't that some people
like to stay at home and others don't
it's that you shouldn't be bound to
pursue a certain life based on the sex
that you were born into at Birth the one
issue I do have is I know actually
um someone a friend of mine whose sister
got involved in the Trad wife movement
in the US basically and she was quite
young she got married to someone who was
like this is what we're doing you're
going to be a Trad wife and basically
came to regret it um she felt like she's
been controlled like her life became
very small and she couldn't get out she
couldn't escape because you know she'd
lost all her friends and and this has
become basically her entire life and it
concerns me that sometimes we see this
narrative on social media that women
have to be a certain way in order to get
her husband and so you have to be this
like particular model of femininity for
people to love you and I think that's
really sad because I don't think anyone
should have to shave off any parts of
themselves to be loved or to you know
find a husband or you know anything like
that all right Paul
what do you think
um I think it's I think it's a good that
we're seeing a return to traditionalism
yeah I think it's a good thing
how I don't know how is the feminist
movement of the last few decades how has
it gone for you and when you look at it
and see how women have progressed do you
think it's been largely a Force for good
or do you think as the Trad wise do that
perhaps we've lost that sense of gender
rules one of a bit of race which
actually worked very well I mean I mean
we've seen families disappear
you know um I saw a study the other day
that said only 25 of I mean this is an
American Staff an American household to
a family so I guess there's positives
and there's negatives but it's like at
what cost you know well like 85 150
years ago the average woman at seven
kids 85 percent of people were married I
mean you know it's higher than mortality
and women died very young and you know I
mean women were more depressed than ever
before we're on antidepressants
women over the age of 45 are the least
happy demographic there are a lot of
very the issue the issue that's reasons
for that and the issue you have is women
like Emily Ratajkowski you know marriage
again I've said this before marriage
isn't marriage anymore the average
marriage is seven years we have things
like no fault divorce leave if you're
unhappy so what does that mean marriage
isn't marriage anymore because now
there's so many marriages over the
course of history where people have been
very unhappy either the man or the woman
has been very unhappy and they've been
forced basically to stay in a marriage
it could have been an abusive
and this is the problem we have with
women like women men tend to be better
people than us yeah they really do they
tend to no no they they tend to do the
right things
I agree there's a reason we have phrases
like a man of his word right yeah
men will actually stick things out women
when gets hard we just leave and
you prove that you're pressing my point
what was your first answer my happiness
right of course
the family doesn't work when it's about
you it's supposed to be about your kids
well and that's the pro that's the
problem everyone no there's a balance
do you think am I allowed to puke
look I think relationships are about
balance they're about compromise they're
about knowing understanding yourself
learning to you know no understand
another person eventually potentially if
you want to bring children into the
world and teaching them how to do that
as well teaching them to balance a sense
of their own identity with the love that
they have for for another person and you
know for example I know um an older
woman actually is friend of our family
who um got divorced at about 60. she had
you know this lovely family they were
together since they were 18 and she said
I got to a point after I'd stopped being
a mother and you know I was just kind of
getting on I realized I'd lost my sense
of who I was and I didn't really feel
like I knew who I was anymore because
I'd always just been a wife and a mother
and I wanted to go out and explore that
and I think
what is traditionalism
um I don't know what you think I would
say a modern mentality is me before the
family I would say traditional
traditionalism is the family before me
especially in women and so and so and so
what I actually it's interesting you
said 60 year olds because you know I've
interviewed 600 700 people roughly in
the past year and a half I've done
hundreds of shows interviewing people
about relationships and what I find is
the 60 year olds tend to
a lot of those women LED their daughters
astray you know there's a reason we're
in this mess right a lot of those women
had the wrong mentality when it came to
marriage and had exactly the mentality
that you're talking about which
prioritize balancing one's own sense of
identity with compromise and
relationships myself before the marriage
but that's again and it's really
unfortunate because I would say the
women of Our Generation really are are
suffering because of the advice of the
women of the past that's an interesting
point here right which is that we do
live in a very individualistic society
and we're all told actually I think a
lot of the time in our relationships as
well you have to be a certain way if you
want to receive love you have to abide
by these uh these Norms you have to be a
certain level of attractiveness you have
to earn a certain amount of money it's
all about you and that's not what love
is yeah all right listen it's actually
been very interesting this into this let
me bringing back in Estes in terms of
trying values Like My Wife puts the bins
out for example right I don't I've never
asked her to she's just adopted that
role in our house so I never put the
bins out I don't know if I should feel
ashamed of myself I do other stuff but I
don't put the bins out as a trans wife
do you put your bins out is that part of
the gender rule of the 50s is that what
used to happen or does the man supposed
to do that I mean how do these rules
work in reality
to be honest it it has nothing it I
don't want to say nothing it doesn't
necessarily have anything to do with the
50s and the 60s
um especially in our household I I
enjoyed the aesthetic and I think that's
where people get a little mixed up with
my channel but um I well to answer your
question actually I I don't put the
charger bins out my husband does that
but
I think we we have this um this thing in
our household where he does most of the
outdoor work I do all the indoor work of
course he works and provides and I'm the
Homemaker that's what works for us but
in relationships in relation to what
right in relation to what Pearl said
it's it's part of a sense of being
dutiful and having no problem actually
with being dutiful in a marriage
uh yes I believe that traditionalism can
it is putting um your family before
yourself and I think it it is
um
it is having those Traditional Values
that were once definitely more in place
in God family and love and we live in a
very selfish Society now you know you
see self-love printed everywhere right
and
um women I speaking of divorce and
marriage women are leaving marriage far
more easy easilier than uh men and they
are doing it because they think there's
something better out there for them that
the grass is greener on the other side
and they're finding out that is wrong
and they're going through divorce after
divorce and um you know marriage is a
bond and it's a sacred Bond where two
become one under God and that's
beautiful and you have to protect that
at all costs and and I think part of
that is putting your partner's needs
before your own every single day and I
try and do my best and I think of my
husband as much as I can and what will
please him and make him happy I'd love
to the sound of this sorry I mean I mean
obviously I don't I wouldn't dare to
express an opinion but you know a lovely
way to think about relationships if it's
reciprocal um you're talking about about
God and family and traditions
finish my sentence
women were supposed to you know
recognize their place and learn not to
speak over other people
um no so look I think it's reciprocated
you talked there about about religion
about Christianity and about self-love
you know the the like most important
commandment there's two most important
moments love your neighbor as yourself
so that requires a foundation of
self-love and respect for oneself and
knowledge of One's Own identity and what
one wants to be able to receive and give
the love that you're going to have in a
solid and healthy relationship I think
it has to be music you're not looking
forward to getting you all back uh in
about 10 years time to see if either of
you two are married and have stayed
married and to see particularly as if
you're still married and still happily
married and still feel exactly the same
way you do today about what marriage
should be that would be a really
interesting thing how happy we are in
general with our lives and all the other
many Rich aspects of our relationships
and our careers and all of these things
yep uh great debate thank you very much
ladies nice to see you all